pourquoi on doit maintien tout ça va
jouer avec lui donner bon accueil aux 80
ou 90 bien qu'il en oublie pas les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
my trop aujourd'hui que vous allez
accueillir c'est ma vie il a 18
victoires et 190
et vous vous aimez bien pris en photo
est ce que quand vous l'êtes vous
arrivez à montrer le vrai nikos le fils
de vos parents par exemple et non pas eh
bien la vedette de télé que l'on connaît
c'est un malentendu la notoriété donc
c'est un miroir déformant donc
effectivement je peux j'ai mis du temps
à prendre faire le sourire de
l'animateur vous savez pas bonsoir
je suis trop bien on va rappeler que
nagui à 73 ans il vient de moselle il a
il est une passion c'est le prix doux
voilà le bridge d'ailleurs il a dit que
le paysage et le widget ans on voulait
dire non le bridge à l'eau parce que si
vous gagnez 20 mille euros vous aviez
dit que vous lui racheter le club de
bridge à côté de votre maison de repos
absolument avec un genou très abîmé et
des douleurs dans le bas du dos elle
franchit enfin la ligne d'arrivée cet
athlète britannique de 35 ans a terminé
dimanche son centième marathon un défi
qu'elle s'est lancée en janvier en
réaliser un par jour pour parcourir au
total plus de 4000 km cette chose ce
soir
salle hier l after fini donner suite ou
slip
avec ce record du monde la jeune femme a
souhaité attirer l'attention sur le sort
des réfugiés syriens les kilomètres
parcourus correspondent à la distance
entre les villes d'alep en syrie et
douvres en angleterre kate jack dunn a
récolté près de 30000 euros lui récolte
des vues sur tik tok et instagram un
petit écureuil est devenu la mascotte
des réseaux sociaux l'animal a élu
domicile depuis janvier sur le rebord
d'une fenêtre d'un appartement du rhône
sous le regard du chaabi scott citron
châtaignes le nom donné par les
propriétaires des lieux et filmé au
quotidien et avec le printemps
l'apparition d'une heureuse surprise
l'arrivée de six bébés écureuils ça fait
du monde au balcon
[Musique]
il te rentre donc c'est quoi la rillette
koné là
c'est une libération de la femme à ce
qu'elle se libère du regard des hommes
c'est ce que disent les défenseurs
soient évidemment saisi les
idées 10h15 audrey berton
berthou
ou rendons évidemment hommage à michel
bouquet qui s'est éteint hier à l'âge de
96 ans ce qui le laisse au théâtre et au
cinéma est un trésor
amassé michel bouquet
qu'est ce qu'elle vous 17 photos
pourquoi les réussie celle là par
exemple alors je sais pas s'il a réussi
mais en tout cas ce moment été pour moi
très très émouvant parce que d'abord
c'était un homme absolument délicieux
témoin du vingtième siècle témoin notre
culture il a incarné avec justesse avec
humilité jamais fait de bruit dans une
époque où tout le monde a quelque chose
à dire vous êtes dans une vision quête
une vision caricaturale de la politique
avait et c'est une décision
antidémocratique
est-ce que tu as it frérot est ce que tu
peux aller chercher mon fils linoa
montorgueil parce que je dois le voir ce
soir et à sa mère et mini qui vont à
quoi elle enfin maé mimie
chercher vinolas au plus vite à
montorgueil il mange à la maison
les deux ans
message à ma grand mère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thibault jour dit aussi grillades et
barbecue
le savon par bus que l'expo ça se passe
et porter la ville s'est même pas d'un
rocher mais c'est le rendez vous des
amoureux des grillades c'est notre
équipe de france avec vous ingrid est ce
que tu breizh on a gagné